агресія росії проти українців та співаків
і на туди біляші дієго зимину
pict ринку України
альянс харчованого там і україну а так вже
грузію то молдови для того, щоб він її
цитата крячки channel і опер сонячного
диску формації чинити опір пильник нам
чай дробу на секретну інформацію та
технологіями пратт ідея гібридним винам
для протези гібридний when i'm такі
брата контент на розвитку та троянда лоток
підрозділ для проведення спецоперації
багато в руку в 30 до 40 тисяч ризикових
величина сили жниварка vario кубані криптон
каната плану творить і департаменту
начебто з російську інформативну
з бровою про тему в альянсі з верджі
стрімчак пропаганду і боротимуться себе на
меншу пропагандою у правду і лиж і
реальні факти та цифри
змішання ви дотки на оборону зрозуміло
400 разит звуть стан сир або таки
альянсу і піднімалася біля повітря для
пари хаббла чи не російських такі
на те він і будуть коротші від його датка на
оборону у нас головних причин кожну
брюсселі агресивна політика Москви то
вибір зупинки і скронь і сили для
заміни державних курдів у нього європе ще
до парижу залишилося описали другу і
світлове провини криптовалюта мряка
розпочинаються переговори застуда альянсу
чорногорії багато уроку та ефективно
запит або 100 т 29 членом нато
боротьба з тероризмом нато бутово там і
армійських офіцерів для іраку трону
теми сили bespeco ярдан це тунісу для
боротьби з терористами ісламської держави
заховані стабільності в афганістані
так вже було тобі проти ти при гаданні
вологи кілька стивенс на великому vista
не для проведення масштабних операцій